[SOUND] So now we will discuss how to
penalize insertions and
deletions in sequence alignment in a more
sophisticated way.
Previously, we used naive scoring for
indels, where
we assigned fixed penalty sigma to each
indel.
However, this fixed penalty isn't good to
represent series of hundreds of
consecutive indels.
And we will call this sequence of k
consecutive indels as single evolutionary
event gap rather than many evolutionary
events of small insertions and deletions.
To model this situation in sequence
alignment algorithms, we'll
use a find gap penalty, where we use two
constants.
One is sigma, which is a gap opening
penalty, and the second one is epsilon,
what, which is gap extension penalty.
And usually sigma is more than epsilon.
Since starting a gap should be penalized
more than extending it, and the formula
to calculate penalty for a gap of length k
will be sigma plus epsilon times k
minus 1.
So let's take a look now how we can use
this in our Manhattan grid.
Previously we had a single edges with
weight sigma to represent insertions and
deletions, and these edges were horizontal
and vertical edges in our Manhattan grid.
Now, we can add more edges.
For example, we can add an edge of a
weight sigma
plus epsilon, which will represent a gap,
a single gap of length two.
And for our Manhattan grid we actually
need to add a lot of these edges.
So we need to add a separate edge for all
gaps of length two.
Edges for all gaps of lengths 3 and more
and
more, and we will need to add it vertical
and horizontally.
How many edges have we added to our graph?
Actually, we added edges proportionally
to n cube, where n is a length of
sequences which we are trying to compare.
Since sequence alignment algorithms' run
time is proportional to
the number of edges, our algorithm will be
quite slow.
It will run proportionally to the n cube.
How we can improve
this running time of algorithm?
We can split our Manhattan grid into three
levels.
Bottom level, middle level, and upper
level.
Bottom level will represent insertions,
and will contain
only edges, which goes vertically from
node to node.
Middle level will represent matches and
mismatches, and will contain diagonal
edges.
Upper level will represent additions, and
will contain only horizontal edges
of our graph.
And still, we need to find a path
between top left corner to the bottom
right corner.
And we can move in our Manhattan grid, but
we also can move between these layers of
the grid.
So for example, we can take one edge
diagonally, and now if we
want to make insertion, we need to move to
the bottom
level, take one edge there, and move back
to the middle level.
And these two edges will represent a
single gap,
where the sigma is a gap opening penalty
and epsilon
is a gap extension penalty.
After that, we can continue moving
on the middle level, for example, we found
a match between our sequences.
And then, if you want to represent
deletion, we need to move to upper level,
make some movements there, and go back to
the middle level.
And we can finish
our path.
To model this mathematically,
we can have three different equations for
dynamic
programming for each level.
And lower level will use
information from lower level itself, and
the middle level, middle level
will use information from all three
levels, and upper
level will use information from upper
level itself and the middle level.
How many edges does this three level
Manhattan grid have?
Hint, is a degree of which node is quite
small.
So each node in this three layered
Manhattan
will have only one, two, or three
neighbors.
And the
number of edges is proportional to the n
square, so the
run time of this algorithm will be the
same as before.
But currently we can use more
sophisticated affine gap
penalty than the native penalty which we
used before.